Let's cross straight over to the mall
now and see what's going on down there
these are live pictures you can see A
procession of Royal cars leaving King
Charles has been hosting a lunch called
the realm of the governor's General and
prime minister's lunch there with many
of the Commonwealth leaders and the
Prime Minister Rishi sunak in attendance
as well Prince William and Princess
Catherine so this is the Royal
procession of cars that has left
Buckingham Palace and we can see that
looks like King Charles getting out of
his car there and doing a walkabout on
the mouth some of the people there of
course been waiting for not just hours
but days ahead of the coronation just to
get a glimpse of the historical event
and perhaps even to get a glimpse of the
people you can see on your screen now
Prince William Princess Catherine there
and indeed King Charles let's have a
listen
[Music]
all right good well hopefully having a
nice weather tomorrow that's the main
thing
well you're very welcome guys have a
lovely weekend
thank you very much
I hope you're very excited for it
[Music]
congratulations
[Laughter]
foreign
congratulations congratulations
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
stop it
tomorrow
[Music]
are you nervous for tomorrow
[Laughter]
[Music]
because there's no one here
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
we love you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
congratulations
we love King Charles in America
[Laughter]
thank you
[Music]
you can see
it
again
tomorrow tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
are you good
thank you
[Music]
have a lovely day tomorrow
yes thank you so much yeah
[Music]
Pakistan
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
as well so it's nice to be out again
hello to everyone who's obviously stayed
out for so long and yeah we'll be
overnight some people are staying
overnight overnight yeah
we're here every day yeah so it's going
to be a long time are you tired a bit
more hours
it is I know it's ready
start tomorrow yes but I think everyone
has a very nice
enjoy tomorrow
[Music]
good job
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
congratulations congratulations
are you excited
congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
let's go
[Music]
I'm out of the way then
and there we had a walkabout there in on
the mall just outside Buckingham Palace
from his majesty King Charles he was
accompanied there on that Walkabout by
Prince William and his wife Kate uh the
three of them taking their time as they
walked up the mall we were just a meter
away from them as they came up the mouth
of their shaking hands of the people
who've been waiting some of them since
last night
to meet the Royals and to be here for
the big day tomorrow as you can hear
we're in the middle of the crowd at the
moment uh in fact you can't see me
because I cannot get in front of my
camera so we're right in the in the
front row here at the beginning at the
the front of the crowds people pushing
past us it was quite extraordinary what
was a very polite and spaced out uh
crowd suddenly surged forwards as the
members of the royal family came across
to shake hands and meet members of the
public who have been here some of them
as I say uh four a day we're seeing them
now getting back into their cars making
their way into Clarence house after this
walk around so as I say they're they're
Prince Prince William Princess Kate and
His Majesty King Charles there walking
around the crowds waving them off as
they return in fact to Buckingham Palace
returning back in their cars to
Buckingham Palace there